juste eu des gens pensent que vous
meniez j'en pense
avec moi j'ai comprendre je serais à la
place des gens je comprends tout à fait
je ne serais pas d'accord mais le
problème le problème moi c'est comme je
connais la loi
je sais que la loi est comme ça alors
moi je ne suis pas je ne sais pas il n'y
a pas d'accord moi je ne savais pas du
tout prix sinon rien n'avait rien volé
rien détériorer notre intention n'était
pas ça il faut le savoir
opel qui sont rentrés par effraction
bien préservés
oui bon vous pouvez toujours chanté que
voulez vous pouvez élever la voix lever
la voix crier même si vous national et
le texte n'est pas parce que vous allez
écrire ce que vous allez impossible